today we are discussing every hashra aka
the strongest demon Slayers in the
history of Demon Slayer all 13 including
legendary former hashira will go over
the secrets and powers of water
hashiragiyu missed hashira Prodigy
muichiro love hashiramitsuri strongest
hashirag and everyone else so make sure
to stay tuned for that including ranking
all of the hashira at some point in the
video smash that like button until you
see fireworks if you like seeing
demonstrator videos like this one and
want to keep them coming make this the
video you joined the demon saying fam if
you haven't already by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future Demon Slayer videos and updates
spoilers ahead first let's turn to the
former hashira the people that ran the
show before our current generation first
let's look at jiguro kuajima the Sensei
or grams of our boys anitu he is the
former Thunder hashira and the actual
title for a thunder style using hashira
is Rumble hashira if you didn't know he
retired from being a hashira at the the
age of 35 when he lost his right leg
from the knee down in the middle of a
battle as revealed in the first fan book
he was a master of the Thunder breathing
style and tried to teach all six forms
to his students zenitu and kaigaku
however zanitsu could only Master the
first while kaigaku could Master the
other ones but not the first and
foundational form we get flashbacks of
how he rescued zaritsu from that and
tried to drag an unwilling and winding
zany to back the training he'd
encouraged zanitsu telling him he had
talent and when he finally learned one
form gigoro praised him and gave him the
advice if you can only do one thing then
do it superbly polish it to the utmost
of the utmost he'd knock zaito on the
head and tell him to forge a katana you
strike it and strike it and strike it to
drive out the impurities and refine the
purity of the steel that's what makes a
strong sword he was so tough when it
came to zainitsu's training because he
wanted to rid zenitsu the crybaby of his
impurities so he could be become a blade
that's stronger than any other While
others gave up on zaritsu jigoro never
did he'd scold him over and over again
he would always pull sanitu back when he
ran away even though zanitsu said he
went too far sometimes the important
thing for xanitu was that jigoro never
gave up on him and zayto himself
realizes as early as the mountain not
the Guma Ark that thanks to his Gramps
he grew strong so that he could now
dream of helping people now you might be
thinking if giguro had two students who
did he want to be his Rumble hasha
successor well he wanted zaitu and
kaigaku to share the title which seems
fitting since alone they didn't know all
the forms but together they did know all
the Thunder breathing forms however
kaigaku was insulted by this thinking
he's so much better than zanitsu when he
crossed paths with upper Moon Juan
kokushibo he was quick to accept the
offer to become a demon and eventually
become upper Moon 6. jiguro a man of
Honor committed seppuku because the
wielders of Thunder breathing had
produced a demon as Saints ran in a
letter he died all alone and there was
no second there to cut off his head so
he's suffered in agony before dying he
didn't make it quick even though he
could have because a student of his
became a demon zainichu gets more
serious than ever after he reads this
letter and starts preparing to avenge
his Gramps by taking down now upper Moon
six kaigaku zenitsu greatly respected
and loved jigoro and even told kaigaku
that he feels sorry that Gramps had such
pathetic successors ironically zanitsu
hukaigaku thought was so far below him
actually defeats the upper Moon by using
his own creative Thunder breathing form
form 7 flaming Thunder God kagaku thinks
jigoro favored zanitsu and taught him
that secret form but zenitsu told him no
he created it and gigoro wasn't that
kind of person after the fight zenitsu
is temporarily close to death and sees
gigolo's Spirit on the other side of a
river he apologizes for everything for
not paying off his debt for not becoming
a hashiranjuguro's lifetime for being
the reason kagaku turned into a demon
and so on but jigaro just tells him with
tears in his eyes that he's proud of him
jiguro wasn't just a rumble he also
succeeded in helping to create one of
the strongest swordsman in zenitsu who
went on to create the strongest form of
Thunder breathing yet it's all the more
impressive that jiguro forged him from
the crybaby he used to be from Crybaby
to creating his own and strongest under
breathing form soloing an upper Moon and
playing a big role in defeating the
demon king of Pop once and for all so I
think it's safe to say that his students
added to more than made up for the
disappointment of his other student
kaigaku next we have everyone's favorite
hashira former flame hashra shinjuru
rengoku and yes I'm being sarcastic this
dude is easily the most hateable of the
hashira despite being the Epic Kyogre
and Goku's father when kyojuro told him
he became a hashira shinjuru responded
with no one cares when kyojura died
shinjuru said he was a worthless and
stupid son the first fan book even
reveals he hates animals and that's why
his children can't have pets but it
should be noted that shintra's life has
been a roller coaster ride and he wasn't
always the short tempered abusive drunk
that he is during the main story kyojuro
himself says that he didn't used to be
like that he became a hasha with
enthusiasm and even raised his children
enthusiastically but then he changed
there are a couple of notable reasons
for this one is that his wife JoJo's
mother fell ill and died another is that
he adopted a very pessimistic view of
the world namely that a person's
capabilities and limitations are set at
Birth a rare few enter the world with
talent and the rest are just rabble with
no value he viewed himself and kyojuro
as being in the latter category he loses
it when he sees tanjiro's hanafuda
earrings and says that he's a
practitioner of sun breathing he attacks
tanjiro and even though he's been
drinking tanjiro can't help but notice
that he's so fast and no amateur a nod
to how skilled he must have been as a
hashira eventually shinjuro explains
what he read from historic flame hashida
records that sun breathing is the first
breathing technique and the strongest
all other breathing techniques are
nothing more than imitations lesser
forms when he read this he started to
resent users of sun breathing thinking
himself hopelessly inferior to them he
developed an inferiority complex that
made it seem like there was no point to
anything if you weren't one of the
Chosen Few a skilled user of sun
breathing however even his own history
disproves that we find out that he saved
iguro from the female serpent demon
iguro went on to become the serpent
hashira and although we don't know how
many countless people he saved off
screen we do know that he goes on to
play a crucial role in helping Tanja to
defeat muzon so by saving him shindro in
a way is to be thanked for all the good
igoro went on to do afterwards just like
kyojuro is to thank for all of the good
tanjiro goes on to do after he saved him
from akaza but shinjuru is not as
heartless as he seems at first glance
even in the present yes he said those
awful things about his dead son but when
he's alone he bursts into tears crying
out his son's name it becomes clear that
in part he didn't want to encourage his
son past because he didn't want him to
end up dead like this we see an eventual
change take place in shinjuro after
kyojiro dies in the past he used to
drink on the job before kyojiro replaced
him as hashira in fact as we find out in
kyojiro's Side Story because of his
drinking shinjiro failed to finish off a
dangerous demon that would eventually
want revenge get stronger and become
lower Moon too this demon recalls an
image of shindro who held and drank
alcohol as he was fighting he was way
stronger than the demon at the time and
diced his flesh and hard into pieces he
caused fear and rage in that demon but
left him alive fortunately kojo
eventually finished a job but who knows
how many people suffered in the interval
because of shinjiro's drunkenness and
failure to take his job seriously
however in This Side Story we see a
flashback of kyojiro telling his little
brother that their father will pick
himself up one day and he does but
unfortunately it takes the death of his
oldest son to do it during chapter 147
we see shinjuru sober and helping out
along with fellow former
they are serving as bodyguards for kirya
and his siblings shindro even says like
kyojurum I will risk my life to protect
them so as not to bring shame upon house
rengoku so it's good to see that kyojuro
sets such a good example that even
shinjuro eventually came to a senses and
got back on the right path next we have
the former waterhashra sakonji urokodaki
arguably the most popular former
hashiram he was tanjiro's first mentor
and the opposite of Shinju in many ways
not just elementally but in the fan
books it's revealed that sakonji doesn't
drink alcohol and has a very low alcohol
tolerance he also only makes Fox masks
because he likes foxes so he likes at
least one animal unlike shinjuru also in
a fan book it's revealed why he wears a
mask which I thought was a pretty hype
reveal it's because demons used to make
fun of his gentle face we also learned
that he receives money from ubuyashiki
but never spends it on himself
preferring to live a self-sufficient
lifestyle he does use it to pay for
nutritious food that he gives to
tanjirotho so all around we already get
the sense that sakonji is a stand-up guy
he also shares similarities with the
real-life swordsman Legend Miyamoto
Musashi he described his style in the
book of water meditated in remote
mountains in his older years and also
had a long line of students who met
unfortunate ends he also wrote the book
of five rings around 1645 which people
still recommend as must-read
self-development reading to this day now
we actually get a bit of a parallel with
shinjuru when we look at sakonji's
backstory whereas shinjuru seems to have
let his demons survive through drunken
incompetence sakonji purposely seems to
have let the hand demon live on so that
he could serve as one of the final
selection obstacle demons because the
konji captured him and imprisoned him
there the hand demon hates sakonji and
takes pleasure in killing sakongji's
disciples that make it the final
selection this demon killed 13 of
sequence's apprentices including sabito
and makomo now let me know if there's a
satisfying explanation for this but this
almost feels like a plot hole to me
because of how stupid it seems when I
think about it if I was sakonji I would
have killed the hand demon personally
long before the number reached 13 or at
least stopped making my students targets
by giving them Fox masks that the hand
demon could use to identify and Target
his students the only reason this could
be seen as less bad than what shinjuru
did by letting his demon live is that at
least people willingly enter the final
selection exam knowing the risks while
shindro's demon could have killed
innocent people as well but back to the
story sakonji trained guiu as well a
sign of his skill since water how should
I give you is not only strong but was
skilled enough to create his own water
breathing form Dead Calm goo is the one
who asks him to train tanjiro and he
does after Tundra passes his tests we
see that sakonji is very skilled during
tanjiro's training Arc tanjiro calls him
ridiculously strong and he easily beats
tanjiro in the beginning even though
Tanja has a sword and sakonji is
sparring unarmed after a year he tells
tanjiro he has nothing more to teach him
he insists that he needs to figure out
how to split a giant boulder by himself
before he will approve tanjiro's
entrance into the final selection exam
and I assume we all get why he wants to
make sure tanjiro can do something so
insane before entering because he
doesn't want yet another Apprentice to
die at the hand Demon's hands in fact
sakonji even says he had no intention of
sending Tanja to final selection and
seeing another child die so konji
thought he wouldn't be able to split the
boulder but when he does secondary a guy
who could be violent to Tanja during
training tenderly pass him on the head
and says he did well he calls him an
amazing child and tells him to go to
final selection and to return alive then
of course he gives tanjiro a fox mask
because he says it protects people from
evil but again in my view it more so
makes him a hand demon Target all the
while sakonji has been taking very good
care of nezuko and he continues to do so
when tanju goes off to the final
selection of course when tando comes
back from final selection sakonji is
over Overjoyed he group hugs Tanja
nazuko with tears running down the side
of his face saying he's glad Tundra came
back to them alive when Hagan Azuka
comes with Tundra's sword both he and
sakanji hope tanju's sword will turn
bright red from the get-go only for it
to turn black so konji lets Tundra know
that he gave nezuko's subconscious
suggestions to defend humans from demons
as if they were her family now already
sakonji seems like a good guy but this
becomes even more apparent when we find
out that he sent a letter to buyashiki
asking him to forgive tanju for
harboring a demon and promising that if
nezuko ever killed a human he along with
Tundra and gyu would commit sepugu to
repent in other words the dude is
willing to risk his life to help Tanja
nazuko later while shinjiro is
protecting kiria sakonji is protecting
nazuko a prime target for muzon once
again he's risking his lies for these
kids in the extended demonstrator ending
we even see sakonji take off his mask
once the world is at peace again and the
demon threat has been dealt with but at
the same time the mangaka only shows us
the lower part of his face which wears a
gentle smile wanting to keep the mystery
of his entire face alive for us even
while the characters in Demon Slayer
would now know what he looks like and
it's fitting that he takes it off and
can celebrate this new peaceful world
with his students bare-faced because if
you'll remember he only wore the mask to
begin with because of demons next we
have former flower hashirakana kochro
the older sister of insectasha shinobu
and if you didn't know the love interest
of wind hashira sanami as we'll get into
Kanai and shinomu lived a peaceful life
with their loving parents before a demon
attacked the demon took the lives of
their parents and was about to take
theirs before they were saved by the
strongest hasha yomei himejima after
this they decided to become demon
Slayers in the hopes that they could
prevent others from experiencing what
they experienced later at sanami's first
hashra meeting she was present sunmi was
mad thinking that ubiashiki only viewed
demon Slayers like his friend who died
masachi as pawns it was Kanai who
stepped in and told him that that wasn't
the case ever since he became their
leader he memorized all the names and
backgrounds of the corps members who
died that was a little clue that these
two specific hashira would grow closer
in a fan book yomei would later reveal
that sanami seems to like Kane
furthermore Kanai was also important to
kano's life the cultural sisters saved
Canal from a life of poverty and
enslavement they took her to the
butterfly Mansion adopted her and named
her Kano because of her trauma she
couldn't make her own decisions so Kane
gave her the coin she used to help her
make her own decisions furthermore
sonomi reveals that he talks to shinobu
now and then since she's kind of his
little sister clearly he wants to make
sure she's okay since she was so
important to Kanai and Kanai was so
important to him however unfortunately
sanami and Kanai didn't get their happy
ending because upper Moon 2 dolma
entered the picture one day upper Moon 2
Doma was understandably too strong for
her although he couldn't eat her in time
because the sun came came up he did
mortally wound her reminiscing about her
he commented that she was kind and cute
although Kanai wanted shinobu to live
into old age shinobu insisted on getting
revenge so Kane reluctantly described
dolma the demon that took her life to
shinobu this set about an epic story of
Revenge one of my favorites in anime
that would eventually lead to doma's
downfall and we'll get into that when we
talk about chinobu notably dolma did
praise khana's skills telling insect
hashira shinobu that she doesn't have
her older sister's Talent notably
khana's sister shinobu poisoned Doma
while kanal the girl she adopted
finished him off using kanai's own style
flower breathing albeit Kano had some
help from inosuke so like the other
hashira in this list kana's Legacy
continued to help the Demon's air core
long after her passing and now let's
move on to the hashira that our hashira
during the course of the main story next
up we have younger cultural sister and
insectashira shinobu it's easy to
underrate shinobu because she is the
physically weak so much so that she
can't even cut off a demon's head so she
had to utilize poison in her fighting
style however that poison led to one of
the greatest victories and Demon Slayer
over the overpowered upper moon to dolma
I think shinobu's revenge Arc is a
masterpiece I must say as mentioned Doma
did remark that shinobu wasn't as
talented as her older sister and she is
one of the few present hashira that
didn't get a demon Sarah Mark power up
but still Doma did praise her during
their fight he comments that shinobu is
very very fast in fact he says she may
be the fastest hashira he's ever met so
being fastest among not just the other
demon Slayers but the other hashira he's
encountered is definitely High Praise
shinobu's insect breathing move hundred
legged zigzag is especially impressive
she weaves around in all directions in
an advance that destroys the bridge
beneath her feet dolma even remarks that
he can't predict her attack she comes in
from below and pins Doma to the ceiling
of course that doesn't finish off Doma
and he ends up absorbing her but but
even that's part of shinobu's amazing
Revenge plan she's been consuming demon
poison for a long time so that she could
deliver more poison to dolma than she
ever could deliver through a sword I
love patient and well-planned out
strategies like this in the end the
poison kicks in and allows Kano and
inosuke to finish up her moon to Doma
off and it really did make all the
difference even like this they barely
managed to do it however without the
poison inosuke and Kano would have had
their hands full with even the upper
moons ice clones let alone the upper
Moon himself so Props to shinobu her
intellect and knowledge of poisons
allowed her to help take down one of the
strongest demon moons yes it cost her
her life but she got the job done and it
was arguably the most satisfying upper
Moon Defeat in the entire series next we
got sound hashra tengen who retires
after his fight against upper Moon 6
kyutaro and daki he's also one of the
few modern hashira that don't awaken the
Demon Slayer Mark power-up despite how
flashy of a ninja he is and how many
wives he has penguin is just not as
strong as most of the hajra on this list
he played a vital role in the defeat of
upper Moon 6 but lost his hand and eye
in the process even serpent hashtra
igoro calls him out for this saying what
are you going to do about losing your
hand and eye in a fight with mere upper
six implying that tangent should have
dealt with this demon easier and that
iguru and most hashira would have in
fact tanjiro is the one who finally cuts
off gutaro's head and zaritsui nosuke
nazuko and even tengen's wives all
played roles in this fight in contrast
14 year old Miss hashira muichiro as
we'll get to soloed a higher upper Moon
and made it look easy after he awakened
his Demon Slayer Mark still praise must
be given to sound hashratengan for his
bravery and manliness the dude doesn't
even make a big deal of losing his eye
in hand and even after retiring as
mentioned he comes back with shinjuro to
protect kiria and his siblings as with
shinobu it should be noted tengen also
relies on more than just a sword to
fight in addition to his dual Niche it
in Cleavers he also uses explosive beads
in battle these small black beads
explode when cut and are capable of
harming the bodies of even upper moons
next let's look at mitsuri the love
hashira just as tangent's sound
breathing is derived from Thunder
breathing mitsuri's love breathing is
derived from flame breathing in fact
kyojorengoku was mitsuri's mentor and
taught her flame breathing before she
developed her own unique style there are
a lot of unique and interesting things
about mitsuri her green socks to start
with were given to her by Serpent
hashira and love interest iguro her hair
is considered a weird color in the Demon
Slayer world and not just normal
colorful anime hair as we might assume
furthermore her whip-like sword is very
unique we're told it's extremely thin
and flexible the speed of her technique
surpasses even Tangen uzoi's the
narrator tells us and this is before she
awakens her Demon Slayer Mark we're told
her impressive speed is thanks to not
only the flexibility of her Katana but
also her own flexibility and incredible
range of motions her Katana is difficult
to use and liable to cut anyone else who
wields it it was was made just for her a
weapon which only she can use not only
is Tundra impressed by her speed when
she joins the fight against huntengu the
hatred clone is also impressed by her he
launches an attack that should have left
mitsui in pieces but she has a special
constitution in other words her physique
belies or misrepresents her muscle
density she's called the Eightfold girl
because her muscle density is eight
times that of a normal person so her
slender arms should look very jacked
like tengans in terms of how much muscle
power she has but they don't because of
her constitution in other words the
mangaka made her super strong while
keeping her looking very cute although
mitsu was quite impressive during this
fight it Slater made clearer that she is
one of the weaker hashir as well when
iguro gyome Sana mikiu and mitsuri are
fighting moves on together mitsu is
having the most trouble she says she
can't see muzon at all she's relying on
intuition and luck to dodge she predicts
that she will be the first one to fall
and her prediction is correct she's the
first one to be taken out of commission
and igoro rushes in to get her out of
further Harm's Way even though though
she dies as a result of the muzon battle
along with iguro they do get their happy
ending as reincarnations and seeing them
married and running a family restaurant
together is definitely one of the
highlights of the Final Chapter for me
next is flame Goku who as mentioned
actually mentored mitsuri before Demon's
air marks I'd say he was one of the
strongest but unfortunately he never
awakened his own demon Sarah Mark so we
can only imagine how strong he would
have been if he did unlock it as
mentioned kyojuro became a hashra when
he beat the demon his father didn't
finish off that demon went on to become
a lower Moon too but kyojuro was still
strong enough to finish what his father
started however kyjo rengoku's most
impressive fight was definitely against
upper Moon 3 akasa keep in mind that
demon Sarah Mark awakened guiyu and the
hashira or Beyond level tanjiro barely
managed to stop akasa and part of that
as we'll get into was because akasa
chose to stop fighting yet then Goku
without a demon Sir Mark almost be
dakasa now yes this does make rengoku
look good but in all fairness this stay
statement needs to be placed in context
Tundra and GUI were fighting in the
infinity castle where there was no
threat of sunlight in contrast kyjo used
the Rising Sun to his Advantage during
the akasa fight as we'll get into but
let's not get ahead of ourselves from
the beginning akaza is impressed by
kyojoro he can tell kyojiro is strong by
looking at him and comments on how he
developed his fighting Spirit to the
edge of perfection in fact he's so
impressed that he wants to turn kyojiro
into a demon desperately he even says
that kyjo works so hard to build such
magnificent Talent akasa further
comments on his amazing speed and
wonderful sword technique this is all
very high praise coming from such a
strong demon kyotro uses his strongest
form flame breathing 9th form then Goku
which translates to Purgatory in the
anime this attack even takes the form of
a dragon which if you follow my videos
you know that I believe attacks that
take the forms of dragons are especially
strong in the Demon Slayer world when
the dust settles akasa seems to have the
advantage he's given rengoku a mortal
wound through the body with his one arm
however rengoku uses even this situation
to his Advantage even with pierced guts
he summons what akasa calls unbelievable
power he grabs akasa's other hand while
the one that pierced around Goku is
stuck inside still the Don is
approaching to the Panic of akasa and
Goku's sword meanwhile is making its way
through akasa's neck slowly but surely
finally akaza's only option is to tear
off his arms and run away in a panic
before he can even finish off rengoku
although rengoku dies and akasa lives
tendro has a point when he says that
it's akasa's defeat and then Goku's
Victory after all and Goku's goal was to
protect everyone else and he succeeded
in doing that considering how close
akaza was to his end here it's likely
that if rengoku awakened his
demonstrator Mark like the others would
go on to do it would have been enough to
at least take akaza down with him in
this sunrising scenario it's not that
hard to believe that that mass of power
up would have been enough to keep akasa
there a few more moments until the sun
came up and did the rest alas rengoku
didn't awaken it but to me what he did
accomplish convinces me that he would
have been even stronger than demon Sarah
marguyu if he awakened after all even
without a demon's air mark then Goku was
arguably even more impressive against
akasa than demon Sarah Marque even
though the water hashira had a hasha
level or Beyond Tundra there with him
now yes and Goku had the Rising Sun as I
keep pointing out which is important to
note but still it's equally important to
note that without a Demon Slayer Mark he
was able to hold akaza and start cutting
his neck until the upper Moon ripped off
his own arms in a panic and ran away
it's such a shame we never saw
demonstrate marker and Goku because I'm
sure he would have been beyond legendary
next let's turn to water hashragyu who
is known for not smiling and having no
friends as Chernobyl likes to point out
but as we saw during sakonji's part he's
a really good guy who would put his life
on the line foreign
were to ever kill a human even though I
believe demon Sarah market and Goku
would have been even more impressive
that doesn't mean gee wasn't impressive
in his own right we all remember when
the water hashra came in and absolutely
after tanjiro and nazuko were having so
much trouble granted this was early in
the series but GUI looked so untouchable
and overpowered at this point he even
showed his own personally created form
11th form Dead Calm it's almost like a
glimpse of the more overpowered selfless
State Tundra will later awaken for this
11th form gyu ceases body movements and
enters a state of complete Tranquility
it looks like he's doing nothing because
of how imperceptibly fast he is but he's
actually deflecting blocking and cutting
any incoming attacks using this he
completely nullified to his attacks and
made it seem like he wasn't even trying
like he didn't even do anything but this
is no Ultimate Defense as we'll see soon
now let's jump to the akaza fight where
guiyu finally gets pushed to his limits
and Beyond akasa complements used
develops or technique saying it's
wonderful but then he sends the water
hashra flying with his kicks very far
away we're talking through multiple
walls it takes you quite a while to
rejoin the fight however when he he does
he realizes that for the first time in a
long time he's up against a strong
opponent who overwhelms him and he
realizes that his senses have been
sharply honed in a short period of time
he explains senses that were closed off
to him have been awakened and dragged
out to the place where my strong
opponent stands now he understands how
the intense struggle to survive
increases one's skills this is a flexion
of itself where he's pretty much saying
he didn't for a long time have to try
the demons that he encountered were
easily dealt with never challenging him
whatsoever but now thanks to akaza he's
awakened the Demon Slayer Mark akasa
immediately notices that his speed has
increased nevertheless Tundra observes
that akaza quickly adapted to give you
speed then akasa embarrasses Demon
Slayer markugu when he breaks the hashra
sword by punching it GUI only survives
because Salto State Tanja steps in who
is now noticeably stronger than Gio in
this fight akaza uses his strongest
attack final form blue silver chaotic
Afterglow and while Tundra handles it
fine with his new power up Geo tries
using that com and it fails miserably
Geo says the attack wasn't escapable
akasa hit him with a hundred blows
almost all at once he couldn't block
them all even with Dead Calm and then
tanjiro is the one who takes akasa's
head after telling akas that he'd do it
ahead of time Geo contributes a bit by
throwing his broken sword at akasa's
head so he can't hold it to his neck
then he fights the headless body trying
his best to protect a now passed out
tanjiro just as an exhausted gear is
about to reach his limit Tundra wakes up
and is the one who gets gyu out of
Harm's Way as akasa self-destruct so
while akasa could have beaten both of
them if he didn't self-destruct because
they were at their limits Kendra was
definitely the more impressive one in
this fight compared to gyu still gyu was
no slouch and he even goes on to help
during the fight against muzon and as
mentioned he lasts longer than mitsuri
along with sanami gome and iguro during
that battle his blade turns red as well
signifying another Demon Slayer power-up
however despite this eventually he gets
taken out of commission temporarily by
muzon and it even happen to the
strongest hashra gilme so it's to be
expected despite having lost a hand guio
eventually gets back up and helps Tundra
keep musan pinned with his remaining arm
so muzon can't run away from the Sun and
this scene definitely reminds me of a
father-son Kamehameha the way the
mangaka Illustrated it he was one of the
few hashrath to survive after Muslims
defeated he participates in the fight
against Demon King Tundra and survives
that too in the end during chapter 204
we see him United with sakonji nazuko
and Tundra again and we even see a rare
smile on his face fun fact he also
becomes friends with tengen and is even
allowed to hold tangent's baby when it's
born notably Geo also has a descendant
called tomioka gichi that we see in the
final time skip chapter so despite how
reserved and quiet GUI is it seems he
did find a wife eventually and
unfortunately for the gyu extra Nobu
shippers it couldn't have been the late
insect hashira next we have the 14 year
old Prodigy and descendant of the
overpowered tsukuni family that produced
strongest Slayer ever yorichi and
strongest upper Moon kokushibo of course
I speak of muichiro one of the hashra
stars of the current anime season we
just recently saw how he awakened his
memories and got the demonstrator power
up then he used it to absolutely destroy
upper Moon 5 yoko's ultimate form that
was supposed to be harder to cut through
than diamonds tangent singled out
muichiro along with gyome for being
especially talented so it's not
surprising that he ended up being only
one of two characters to ever solo an
upper Moon the other being zenitsu who
beat an upper Moon 6 who was brought in
as a replacement yes you can say
muichiro got some help but that was
before he awakened his Demon's air mark
after he awakened his demon Sarah Mark
not only did he not need help he even
managed to completely outclass final
form gyoko while being heavily poisoned
this match didn't push tokito to his
limit but his next important one did
muichiro participated in the fight
against his ancestor the strongest upper
Moon kokushibu after praising muichiro
kokoshibo draws his sword and since his
it's the first time any of our
characters saw his blood demon art it's
not that surprising that mujiro loses
his hand what is impressive though is
that he doesn't bat an eye the 14 year
old just stops the bleeding and
immediately rushes into attack again
kokushibu even remarks how incredible it
is obviously though he's no match for
kokushibu by himself and kokoshibo
quickly pins him down with his sword
planning to turn him into a demon sonomi
shows up and is not surprised tokito Was
Defeated he says the shape of
kokoshibo's attacks don't have fixed
forms they get distorted making them
impossible to predict sentimi says he
couldn't have survived himself if his
senses hadn't been honed from long
experience so it's implied that that's
why muichiro did worse than sodomy
initially the lack of experience which
makes sense since he's only 14 compared
to sanami's 21. although sonomi and
yomei are present fighting kokoshibo
muichiro still has more to offer he
pulls out the sword and even though he's
in pain and knows he'll die from blood
loss in a few hours he prepares to help
out as best as he can as he says if I'm
going going to die I should do something
useful first and oh boy is he ever
useful muichiro saves ganya then son of
me and then with his remaining arm
manages to get the kokoshibo and to stab
him with a sword at this point we see
that muichiro has awakened the
transparent world power up just as gilme
did during the middle of the fight after
kokushibu takes off the lower half of
muichiro muichiro Still Remains holding
his sword and not just that he even
turns it bright red another important
power up this limits kokoshibo's
movements as he comments that it feels
like his insides are on fire and this
along with genya's blood demon art and
gyome and sanami's skills allows them to
finally take okushibu's head after the
fight muichiro passes away but gyome
even says it's thanks to muichiro that
they were able to win he even comments
that for one so young muichiro really
was magnificent to the end in the
afterlife muchiro tells his twin that he
doesn't regret risking his life for his
comrades so yes he did meet his end
against the strongest upper moon but
also played a vital role in his defeat
and managed to shine line even next to
two of the strongest hashira Demon
Slayer Mark sanami and gome we can only
imagine how strong he would have become
if like sanami and gyome he made it to
his 20s next up we have sanami the went
hashira this dude obviously also
participated in the upper Moon one fight
and as I mentioned it's commented on how
he does even better than muichiro
because of his longer experience
kokushibu himself Hypes up sonami by
thinking to himself that against the
hashra he's encountered so far the
contest would already be over with such
a statement he put sodomy above all the
hashrah he's fought against in his very
long demon life we see his insanely
durable AKA unkillable by keeping his
muscles flexed he can stop his guts from
spelling out when they should something
that kokoshibo states a human shouldn't
be able to do he also has marachi in his
blood which makes demons feel drunk and
thus makes them easier to fight however
as we saw this wasn't a big factor in a
fight against top tier demons like
kokoshibo and muzon another notable
aspect is his wild fighting style there
are multiple instances this is where
you're like wow no other hashra would
have pulled out a trick like that in one
case he blocked kokushibu's sword with a
gun and then fires it sometimes he uses
his foot to hold a sword and so on but
anyways back to the fight Gilmore joins
the fight and both of them awaken a
Demon Slayer Mark another notable thing
is that sonomi works well with gyome as
kokoshibo says in a battle of this speed
they cooperate and sonomi mentions it's
a good thing that the two of them train
together being the strongest husha's
training partner is definitely High
Praise kokoshibo even thinks to himself
that sanami and gomi are highly skilled
even among the hashira albeit he does
single out gyome for being especially
skilled but still no one expected sanami
to be on gyoma's level kokushibu
concludes he'll go after the weaker link
but it's not that easy sunmi quickly
turns his sword when kokoshibo tries to
attack and break it from the side
kokushibu notes that sanami's reflexes
are getting even faster he's becoming
faster and more accurate as the fight
goes on still he never gets to gilme
level and his arms are only spared after
a surprise Goku attack because gilme
used his chain to alter the angle of the
attack as a result Sami only loses some
fingers he is then almost taken out
again but muichiro saves him this time
sonami keeps fighting and along with
Gomez manages to avoid a mortal blow
when kokoshibo sends out countless
Crescent blade attacks we shouldn't
genya aren't that lucky but notably
muichiro's time was already numbered and
he unlike sanami couldn't let go of the
sword he was holding inside of kokoshibo
because it was one of the keys to
Victory sanami and gomi relentlessly
attacked and it suddenly sword that
presses down on Gomez weapon that turns
them red and finally allows them to take
hokushibu's head so sanami definitely
played a key role here when a headless
kokoshibo refuses to go down sanami and
gyo may keep the pressure on with their
incessant attacks kokoshibu can't
believe how no matter how much he cuts
sanami he won't bleed to death
eventually they win not only do sonom
and Gomez survive Gomez notices that
Sunami was fighting unconsciously at the
end there he finally comes to and
doesn't even get the properly more in
his little brother genya because as
Gilmore says this fight isn't over until
they defeat muzon Sunami joins the final
battle by cutting up muzon and then
setting him on fire maybe it doesn't
accomplish much but it looks cool and
again it's creative it's hard to find
another hasha that thinks to throw
bottles that moves on and then to use
the contents of those bottles the set
moves on fire with a match and all of
that in the middle of battle he does all
of this between using his sword like a
normal swordsman he keeps fighting and
is still fighting with the other skilled
hashira when mitsuri is taken down sunmi
notably is still fighting when guiyu
briefly loses his sword and suddenly
tells him to stop spacing out or he'll
kill him suddenly takes damage from
muzon like the others and gets back up
later to help Tundra once he spend muzon
he then attacks giant baby muzon as well
and eventually through a collected
effort they Prevail more hasha present
die than survive but suddenly along with
gyu is one of the ones who somehow
survives despite the fact that kokoshibo
said most would have died early into the
fight against him and sonami went on to
fight muzon later too and still somehow
survives no small feat at the end of the
series after all he's been been through
the dude is still in better shape than
Tangen after his fight against upper
Moon 6 where the latter lost a hand and
an eye sonomi just lost some fingers as
we saw he proves to be one of the
hardest to kill a ball hashira and it's
nice to see that at the end he makes
amends with nazuko who he was especially
cruel to in the beginning and he's sorry
for it next up is the serpent hashira
iguro this may not be obvious from the
anime but in the fan books it's revealed
that these two meaning sonami and iguro
are actually really good friends and get
along well so it's not surprising that
when sanami was mean to nezuko in the
beginning iguro was too pointing out
that they need to attempt her with blood
in a dark room since she can't come out
into the sun iguro likes anime doesn't
come off as a nice guy at first but the
more you get to know them the more you
get to like them as mentioned iguro was
saved from a female serpent demon by
shinjiro rengoku he then went on to
become a hashira and despite being one
of the smallest and weakest hashira
physically he is among the strongest
hashra all around in other words he make
except for his lack of size and raw
power with his speed and skill as a
swordsman he's just hyped up for a long
time and doesn't participate in any
fights on screen he chastises tangent
for losing a hand and an eye to beat a
mere upper Moon 6 and even knowing that
Tenga had a bunch of help too from Tanja
and the others in this way he implies
that he could have taken upper Moon 6 by
himself without getting serious injuries
there's also the fact that the mangaka
saves his fighting for last which is
usually what they do with stronger
characters and Shonen series besides his
strength though which we'll get to soon
perhaps even more importantly is his
relationship with mitsuri as mentioned
he gifted her the green socks she wears
all the time they regularly eat out
together enjoying each other's company
although mitsuri always eats more than
iguro they both love each other but they
both have inferiority complexes and for
iguro's part it's because his family got
ahead by making immoral deals with a
serpent demon and because his own escape
from that demon led to all of their
deaths he feels like his blood is filthy
because of all this and the only way to
purify his blood in his View went to
become worthy of misuri is for him to
die beating muzon and to be reborn again
in a new life where he can then marry
mitsuri's reincarnation and as mentioned
during mitsuri's part he does get this
happy ending in the future and I cannot
be happier about it so now let's see
what he did in the series to earn that
happy ending in the next life igoro and
mitsuri First Take on upper moon for
nakume she's not that strong but she is
tricky one can argue that she was just
brought into fill empty positions and
doesn't even deserve to be an upper Moon
and defensively speaking I'd agree with
that but like I said she's so tricky
that the two hashira iguru and mitsuri
have trouble getting to her even if she
has no more luck being able to finish
them off or hurt them iguru is clear the
more skilled of the two and helps mitsui
when she needs it during the fight
mitsuri's clothes get all beaten up
against nakimek while igurus don't which
is a little clue to you that igoro is
actually the more skilled and on top of
everything eventually the two with
yushiro managed to get the better of
nakime without taking any notable damage
iguru only gets the show where he's
really got against the strongest demon
muzon and his performance is one of the
best during this final battle as
mentioned igoro is keeping up with gome
and mitrigan's Musa keep in mind iguro
is the only one here who hasn't yet
awakened his Demon's air mark power and
yet he is doing just as well as the
others and in some cases better as we
saw when mitsuri got brought down at one
point igoro even says that he can no
longer Shield himejima which is an
insane Flex of a comment Not only was he
doing better than mitsuri who was just
trying to survive he even had enough
skill to worry about shielding someone
else in addition to himself let alone
the fact that that person was the
strongest hashira and I emphasize when
we start this fight we seem to have a
non-demon Sir Mark iguro while all of
the others already have that insane
power-up obviously gome is acknowledged
as the strongest but I think it's
arguable that iguro is the second
strongest because of his Feats in this
battle not saying it's undeniable or
anything but I believe the case can be
made based on all the facts discussed so
far and the facts that will be discussed
moving forward sending me taking second
spot is also a common argument among
fans and in their defense sanami did
fight upper Moon 1 before this and even
survives this fight while iguro does not
so I'll let you guys comment on who's
the strongest between these two below
moving forward do you as mentioned loses
his sword to moves on temporarily and
questions his ability to keep going
iguro steps in to help him until he
bounces back so that we see iguru
awakens his Demon Slayer Mark and turns
his own blade red While most had to get
help from others to get their red swords
it took a lot out of him though and he
nearly fainted so he had to be saved
from muzon's attack in that moment he
then gets a great attack in on muzon and
sodomy notices that even muzon takes
time to regenerate after being cut by a
red blade iguru keeps doing well and
even gains access to the transparent
world something Tundra gained access to
before he beat akaza and that gyome
gained access to during the upper Moon
one fight it's a very top tier power-up
unfortunately muzon still manages to
knock out everyone after a while notably
iguro is the first to recover and jump
in to save tanjiro despite getting so
injured that he can no longer see he
keeps Fighting by having his snake
friend kaburamaru help him out when
mulson tries to run iguro is the one who
catches up and stabs him from above then
when Tundra finally pins muzon igoro
throws himself in front of tundra to
save him from muson's Attack so multiple
times the guy shinjura saved saved
tanjiro the most important person in
beating muzon so again shows how
shinjuru's good deeds did make the
biggest difference in direct contrast to
his previous beliefs that non-sun
breathers shouldn't try because they
can't make any meaningful difference
even after taking the insane point-blank
attack from muzon iguru keeps attacking
giant baby moves on along with the
others and eventually muzan evaporates
in the sun they all succeeded and igoro
was arguably one of the most impressive
but perhaps because he was one of the
most impressive he received fatal
injuries in the process before he goes
though he does have enough energy to go
in Comfort mitsuri who is also dying
they confess their love to each other
and one of my favorite moments in the
series and agreed to get married in
their reincarnated life and thankfully
they do as mentioned in the mitsuri
section next is the strongest hashiraj
yomei himejima the stone hashira he is a
gentle giant when not kicking butt and
is regularly seen crying but don't let
the tears fool you this 27 year old
deserves his title as the strongest
hashira he has a special weapon a niche
chain chain spiked flail and ax the
purity of the weapon is so high that
upper Moon while kokoshibo can't cut
through the chain we saw that kokoshibo
plays gomi as an especially gifted
hashira noticeably above sanami a
skilled hashira in his own right
kukushibo comments like yomei is an
example of the perfect physical form
developed at the utmost he thinks it's
been perhaps 300 years since he set his
eyes on such a great swordsman kokushibu
straight up calls gomey's ability to
wield such a heavy weapon as an
extension of his body with so much
likeness and Agility unbelievable gyo
may even succeeds in Breaking
kokoshibo's sword but it's made of his
flesh so he can easily regenerate it he
does all this before even activating the
demon Sarah Mark power-up when
cooperating with sanami gome manages to
take off kokoshibo's ear keep in mind
that kokoshibo always wanted to be the
strongest Samurai keyword Samurai and
the fact that he got his sword broken
and ear cut off is chipping away at that
image of a samurai eventually when he
becomes all monster and casts off all
pretense of being an honorable samurai
that's when he starts evaporating but
more on that in a bit we're not there
yet we went over how gilmei saved son of
his arm when kokoshibo Unleashed an
unhonorable surprise attack by making
his sword grow longer again something
that a samurai wouldn't be able to rely
upon every type of kushibu Strays from
the path of a samurai in this fight it's
like a little victory for our side and
these little victories add up in the end
during the battle gyome gets a further
prestigious power-up access to the
transparent world and he uses this power
up in knowledge strategically to win the
battle within the high Pace battle it's
a rosary ball from gyome that hits into
kokoshibo's hand with enough force that
changes everything because the rosary
dulled his attack in that moment
everyone was able to land a meaningful
attack especially muichiro it's at this
point that upper Moon 1 points out that
because yomey was able to sense the
transparent world he was able to control
his own blood circulation and that's
what Disturbed kokoshibo's attack
obviously this opened up the window for
everyone to gang up on kokoshibo
including genya with his op blood demon
art with Jutsu Powers gyomi along with
sunmi avoids taking lethal damage from
another desperate surprise attack from
kokoshibo where sword Sprout from all
over his body and finally it is Gomez
giant spiked ball which turns red after
sanami uses his sword to add Force to it
that takes off kokoshibo's head here the
fight if kokoshibo was a non-demon
samurai would be more than over already
even if he was most demons it would be
over but like musan and nakasa kokoshibo
appears to be powerful enough to regrow
his head even while gyome and sanami are
attacking the body without rest but now
he looks nothing like a Samurai and
completely like a monster in these cases
where the head grows back as we saw with
akasa the upper Moon usually needs to
psychologically give up to stop
regenerating and this happens when
kokoshibo sees his monstrous reflection
in sanami's Sword he's shocked and says
referring to himself what is this it's
so ugly he asks himself is this how a
samurai looks he questions if this is
really what he wanted and then after he
starts to question himself his body
starts dissolving from where mujiro
stabbed him he talks about the ugliness
of not admitting defeat even though they
took off his head and of living in
disgrace and becoming a monster all
because he was so scared of defeat he
says he became a miserable creature
before he completely disappears now all
this time gome and sunny were pressing
kokoshibo to the point where sanami had
passed out and was fighting
unconsciously and had to be told by
Gomez when to stop then yomey is the one
who reminds son of me once he comes to
that it's not over until they beat muza
so after all that gyome didn't faint
like sanami and is ready to keep Bond
fighting immediately and he does help
during the final battle even receiving
fatal injuries in the battle however he
doesn't shine as much as Igor in the
final battle as I talked about and
that's probably because Gil May shine so
much during the upper Moon one fight and
the magaka needs some time to develop
iguro and give him his moment as well
and we gotta be fair iguro fought a
tricky but not that dangerous nakame for
a bit which you can't compare to
gilmay's fight against the strongest
upper Moon so iguro was coming into his
final battle a lot fresher nevertheless
Gomes was great and contributed to
defeating muzon even continuing to fight
and help stop giant baby moves on after
losing a leg now you may have gotten a
sense of the way I'd ranked the hasha
while explaining them so let's enter the
ranking portion of the video we do know
that this is an especially strong
generation of hashira and so this would
make me want to put jigoro urokodaki and
shinjuro in the bottom tier yes we have
some cool Feats from shinjuru
specifically like saving igoro from a
serpent lady demon and for embarrassing
a demon that would go on to become a
demon Moon while drunk but the fact
remain means we haven't seen any of them
take on demon moons on screen so can't
make crazy cases for their power we then
have Kane shinobu and Tangen who didn't
awaken demonstrator marks and didn't
come off as especially strong among the
current generation Doma did say that
Chernobyl wasn't as strong as her sister
which is one of the reasons Kana is in
this tier but I also think shinobu
should be given credit her goal was to
make sure Doma eats her and ingest the
poison within her and she accomplished
that after being pretty impressive in
the fight especially speed wise she
still has tear to me because even if she
was physically too weak to cut off a
demon's head I think her speed and
poisons made up for it to an extent and
although it took sacrifice in her life
she did play a key role in taking down
upper Moon too something kinda I
couldn't even do next mitsu should
probably be put here in her own tier she
did awaken a demonstrator mark and held
her own for a very long time against
upper moon for hantangu's strongest form
zohakuten who wasn't toying around
either she went on to help against
nakime and then even against muzon she
just couldn't keep up with the other
skilled hashira against muzon then we
got a broader tear here in which I'd put
gyuren Goku and muichiro muichiro is one
of the most naturally gifted hashira and
I mean the dude soloed an upper moon at
14 years old and yeah he could have
easily made it to the top tier but he
just lacked experience as we saw that
lack of experience did come into play
asanomi pointed out when it came to a
super strong opponent like upper Moon
one perhaps it's weird I'm putting a
character who didn't awaken a demon
Sarah Mark here but he's the mentor of
mitsuri and he did amazingly well
one-on-one against akaza so I have to
personally put that on Goku here as well
I just couldn't put him any lower guiyu
for his part is not higher up in my view
because despite Awakening a demon Sarah
Mark he wasn't that impressive in the
akaza fight and completely took a
backseat to tanjiro in the muzon fight
he dropped his sword first among the
remaining highly skilled hashira while
the others had to step in to save him
and give him a pep talk now again I'm
not saying you can't argue that gyu
could be in the top tier I'm sure a lot
of people would like to but for me
personally I'd put him here based on
what we've seen in the biggest battles
and now the top tier of hashira goes to
sanami iguro and of course gome at the
Pinnacle for Sunday I'm impressed by how
he just doesn't die the dude goes
through so much damage so many fights
impresses upper Moon one by being able
to fight him one on one for a while even
when most hashira would have been dead
by that point as kokoshiba points out
and the dude makes it to the end of the
series in the best shape no arm or leg
missing iguro like I said then come from
a hard fight like upper Moon one but he
did exceptional in the muzon fight being
able to keep up with the best and even
Shield others even before we see his
power-ups like Demon Slayer Mark and red
sword and acts as a transparent world
and so on he also gets up first after
everyone faints and as a result helps
Tanja the most out of any hot
against muzon and then of course gilme
is an easy one he's acknowledged in the
series and by the other hasha as being
number one and should maybe have his own
tier as even Toshiba said in black and
white he was above sonami he unlocks the
overpowered transparent world power up
as well and uses it to turn the tides of
the upper Moon one fight with a rosary
ball and after that continues to help
stop muzon right up to the end even when
he's only got one leg remaining And I
stress it doesn't bother me if people
rank them differently like in the
comments for example just explain your
reasons if you got him it all depends on
how you make your argument now the hasha
were strong I'll give you that but the
demon moons get even stronger so if you
enjoyed this one you won't want to miss
the companion video all 18 demon moons
explained and ranked on screen right now
and I'll see you there